Chris Pratt and Anna Faris have
officially finalized their divorce this
is just in finalizing the divorce but
factoring in a few compromises the
former couple has agreed to live within
5 miles of each other for the next five
years everybody's kind of talking about
this point in the documents that have
come out and to join me and break it all
down is Brendon Jeffery on from our 18
news desk Brendon
so everyone's talking about Chris Pratt
and honor because this detail sticks out
I'm not sure I've ever heard this in a
divorce settlement from a celebrity
couple before can you think of anything
else and kind of what's the reaction to
that five-year thing I haven't it's
definitely I've never heard of it it's
definitely something new for me and I
think it's new for a lot of people I
mean it is the headline that is making
news this morning it's very interesting
I didn't know that this was something
that existed but it is very interesting
and we know that either of the couples
need to approve further than 5-mile like
if they want to go more than 5 miles
they want to change this they have to
get the other person written notice no
later than 3 months in advance of the
move so there's a lot in place here it's
a very interesting stipulation if you
will interesting you know I can see it
both ways on the other hand a little
unusual I mean a little unusual but on
the other hand they've both said that
their focus is on their son Jack he's
still very young living within 5 miles
of each other for the next few years
would just take them through Jack
completing the sixth grade so he's such
a little guy and I understand that they
kind of want to prioritize both being
able to be in his life Anna
having a little bit more of a stable in
LA area schedule being on CBS's hit show
mom Chris of course with movies he
travels for those quite a lot now the
couple split just about a year ago we
know that they've both moved on with
other people
Chris dating Catherine's Schwarzenegger
and Anna dating cinematographer Michael
Barrett but they were just spotted out
together for it was trick-or-treating
right both of the couples right on
Halloween we saw them all together here
in the LA area trick-or-treating with
the kids
we know from sources that they are both
happy for each other in
new relationships there's no bad blood
here this was a very amicable split
between both we also know that there
will be many more holidays in the future
where we will see very similar to what
we saw on Halloween where they are all
together as a family it's really it is
it's refreshing and good to see Brendan
because you know sometimes with
different work schedules and where
people have to be in Hollywood for all
their different projects this has
complicated stuff to work out just this
week we got those docs on Brad and
Angelina Brad Pitt and Angelina Jolie
they've split over two years ago now and
they're just getting a trial date for
their custody trial so good to see Chris
and Anna kind of working things out just
about a year later and moving forward
with this agreement
[Music]
[Applause]